نشأت [موسيقى]
من تحت الرماد
قادرة على التغلب على المحن ومشغولة للغاية
بحيث لا يمكن الكراهية والتي أصبحت في نهاية المطاف
شعار المدينة على
مدى القرن الماضي ربما لم تقم أي
شركة بتشكيل صورة أتلانتا
كعاصمة هذا الجنوب الجديد
وكوكاكولا
أتلانتا وفحم الكوك وكذلك  يقول
سويًا
الشيء الحقيقي مرحبًا بك في
عالم الكوكا كولا ،
لدي السر وفقًا لأسطورة
الشركة ، تم اختراع الشراب السري في عام 1886 بواسطة
صيدلي محلي
قام بإقرانه بالمياه الغازية
، ثم تم بيعه كمنشط للدماغ
لتخفيف الإرهاق
تتناغم الإعلانات مع الشعار
حتى الزجاجة والزجاجة المميزة بحيث
يمكن
التعرف عليها عن طريق اللمس في الظلام أو عند
الكذب على الأرض
تذوقها كلها معًا ،
يمكن القول إنها
العلامة التجارية الأكثر شهرة في العالم وهنا
يمكنني تذوق الطيبة العالمية
السيئة والقبيحة الثمانية
يأتون حول العالم عفواً
[موسيقى]
من السويد
لطيفة في يوم صيف حار ولكن ليست
بيرة الزنجبيل الصخرية المثيرة للغاية من
تنزانيا  أشعر
أن السكر الآخر في هذا في
الواقع له مذاق
رائع والآن قيل لي أن
طعم بيفرلي من إيطاليا يتغلب على جميع الأذواق ،
إنه تنافسي غير كحولي
يبدو
رائحته جيدة
[موسيقى]
أوه ، هذا هو أنا  لست متأكدًا من أنه حتى الكولا
يمكن أن يعلم العالم أن يحب ذلك
مع وجبة خفيفة لطيفة يمكن أن تكون على ما يرام ولكن
في الوقت الحالي
أنت